hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to yet another exhausting
day or yet another day exhausting
prototype as it says on the title there
you imagine that you're coming home from
work or you're just waking up and the
entirety of life is just a burden upon
your soul you can't be bothered to do
any [ __ ] you can't be bothered to put
any energy into any activity that you
have planned for that day you are just a
human slug trying to slide your way out
of bed and through life so that you can
eventually make your way back that's who
you are in this game and that's what
this game represents as far as I know
and I can relate to that very heavily
and I'm pretty sure that many of you can
relate to that
oh god you are too jiggly for my tastes
hello as a young professional with the
promising future my life in the city is
overwhelmingly tiring yeah me too buddy
me too I am exhausted
yeah me too buddy so what are you gonna
do about it
ha you won't get yet I cannot sleep
maybe so the energy drinks you cram down
your gullet maybe you think about that
every once in a while what did I do
sense lessons in time causing you to
fall asleep okay
husky husky let me just pelvic thrust
into the ground whoa
[Laughter]
is he gonna get this eventually I don't
know what I'm doing yeah wait Boosh okay
here we go I'm really scooching my touch
school [ __ ] douche there we go that's
good okay sans increases from external
stimulation okay like what oh well all
right okay here we go
I'm not okay if you barely even move it
[Music]
stimulation you mean cramming my head
into the objects oh no all right I'm
gonna roll for it I'm rolling for
initiative I think this is what they
call twerking but I'm not arms insurer
okay let's try I'm guessing I'm going up
this wall okay
I think we're free there I go
he's beauty he is grace he will slide
upon his face what a beautiful man snake
man who's the greatest game you know
this is the kind of the kind of
innovation that the gaming industry
needed excuse me expected to go that way
I'm sorry I just imagine this man
slamming his testicles into the ground
as hard as he can
oh [ __ ] oh okay pillows are naptime
death
come on husky oh come on what are you
magnetized to the goddamn pillow is a
Velcro on your head he's stupid idiot
husky get up there hurry
ow no no no don't roll Wow
ow can you not ah early knock some sense
in oh oh okay we're okay let's get out
of here here we go that's what I'm
talking about
it's a good game there's a good game no
don't roll
why do what was even the point of
rolling why would you want to roll oh
that's gonna go too far
Oh smart smart man smart man I am smart
man I am go up the sides then my head
can't hit it
I am so goddamn smart oh go go go go go
go go I don't care go no no no no you're
fine yeah you're fine buddy you're fine
this is this is the goddamn greatest
game ah after finishing a page of
Murakami I post an update sharing my
wisdom of living offline huh oh okay
good that's great oh my head becomes
heavier yeah welcome to my world my my
heavy ass head no don't roll why are you
rolling why what is the point of rolling
there's no point
what you're rolling be a separate button
I'm away bad my Tom I'm really gonna get
it huh yeah uh-oh I got eaten by the
pillow Wow all right then well I guess
this is what we're dealing with maybe if
I go ask first into the pillow it won't
be so bad no don't don't roll don't
all right you just goddamn sweet pea how
about you listen to my [ __ ] words why
don't you maybe that's what I need to do
maybe rolling is like the answer okay
I'm gonna try roll there we go roll no
there's no you stop what what what are
you doing everyone can see my mouse
everyone knows you're [ __ ] stupid Wow
[Laughter]
sure we're gonna go with the big old
sure no no no no no no no no this is
impossible I would anybody do this you
can't do this it's impossible okay well
then that's just stupid it's like as
soon as I touch it I barely touch it and
it's a [ __ ] recoil pull my head out
of the way I must slide my head back
okay no I'm gonna do this apparently go
go go go god [ __ ] duhkha damn it [ __ ]
a duck a dick what the [ __ ] ah you
sentence
you piece of [ __ ] you garbage human you
garbage human garbage human even though
I relate extremely heavily just you're
really messing up my steez right now
[Music]
okay all right progress get my head out
of the way no no no no get my head No
okay this is bad is bad is bad it's bad
bad know what I'm done stop it just stop
okay keep it in the leaves smell the
leaves real hard sniff those leaves
we're gonna do we're gonna make a break
for it when we get an opportunity we're
gonna really douche for it either
there we go yes yes that was [ __ ]
impossible why is that so hard
crazy dog perfect exactly what I needed
oh yeah that's cool excuse me while I
just hang onto this ledge by my nose boy
ah good [ __ ] good [ __ ] indeed I said we
just got a skate right by these things
excuse me light oh yeah easy-peasy easy
breezy beautiful me Oh
oh boy I'm just so bold
okay I'm just dead all right so I got to
Ram my head into the nearest object as
fast as I can
[ __ ] go for it Ram baby don't you run
away from me
hey got him
no no you you you addict you sleep at it
just get away from it you don't even
have to touch it you don't have to do
anything to it just don't do nothing
stupid there's a shitty Rolly bastard
you [ __ ] Rolly pole here why do you
want to roll so badly
this is no reason to No don't roll yeah
let's try to go for this guy coming in
for No
oh I'm so mad all right here we go we're
gonna come in for a landing and then
we're gonna get our head out of here
whoa ah now I'm getting it now I'm
getting the rhythm I think I could have
just guns for this right off the bat I
guess I didn't really need to wait for
anything but oh well there we go
easy peasy lemon squeeze all work time
yes please I guess got a ram night oh
[ __ ]
I guess I got a ram my head let me just
do this by my nose you're a warrior now
let the adventure begin I calmly embark
on my darkest journey okay
why that's bizarre playing D&D head
becomes heavier yes I cannot sleep okay
it's impossible I'm from the Russian Oh
God oh my
everything is pain oh oh oh oh that's
not right that's oh hi Rolie polies
Roomba oh oh no okay
bonk okay what I'm gonna give a big old
yeah right to that one there's no way
that worked
no don't roll you just go for it you oh
my god why is this Roomba have a
vendetta against me and since when can a
Roomba fluff a pillow for me whatever
you know I'm all for that mad dog you
can't stop me
Rev try me miss me [ __ ] no don't roll
if there's no point of rolling the only
reason that rolling exists is to get in
the way which i think is a fascinating
game mechanic by itself like you're so
tired I can't help but do 360s in my
snooze like it's such a stupid mechanic
it doesn't work just do anything yeah
just barely get my nose in the boy no
miss me miss me bet you want to kiss me
oh I want to gosh [ __ ] no God right to
it oh ah ah you are not right to it and
then you went to right to something else
you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like I have the
most simple of rass in the eye yeah
that'll wake me up I feel great now [ __ ]
yeah man Roli pull okay why oh where are
you going what the hell was that
manoeuvre
what did you just do how did you break
physics I mean you're on the wall so I
guess you already are breaking physics
what the hell man okay
wait how wait wait wait Rollie pollie oh
my god get stand on your legs man
and on your legs you can't this is
impossible well [ __ ] me
well that's impossible there's no way
what oh that got rid of that pillow but
that didn't do anything for me so
there's something to breaking glass and
that helping in some okay goodbye
oh he looks a little concerned huh
you guys you have no purpose anymore
secure just drifting aimlessly
I'm so sorry me too man ah what the [ __ ]
okay you you're terrified man oh oh my
god
I am so sorry I did not know the powers
I had inside my soul I think what I have
to do is I have to blow that guy up here
so I gotta I gotta like I think I just
got a [ __ ] ramen I think that's all I
got to do right so I'm just gonna charge
this bastard you think you can get away
from me huh you think you got me huh oh
[ __ ] you do not get [ __ ] no don't roll
oh [ __ ] oh okay well that didn't work
out but the idea is there well maybe I
gotta like make him afraid because he
ran away from me so that must be a thing
so if I get these that one goes away and
there he goes he now he's running away
from me yeah
no oh [ __ ] God oh okay I gotta get
behind him cuz he's gonna back away from
me right to go no go
why does he just back up why does he do
this why does he only go to this corner
Oh
caffeine gives me immunity oh that if
that makes a lot more sense than what I
was trying to do okay well I'm just a
big dumb dummy Oh after 15 push-ups i
order half a fried chicken imagine all
the muscle I will gain in a month I
laugh oh okay
what is your life are you one punch man
oh is it time is it finally time for
Snoozeville please please let it be time
oh sweet find the sweet embrace of sleep
Oh
cutscene at last there is still a long
time before tomorrow
having squeezed every drop from my day I
giggled like a big baby
I'm tired heart has found peace I can
finally rest my eyes you know a big baby
like a big baby you know me oh that was
nice I got stuck because I was stupid
but that was really nice that was really
really nice I like that oh what a cutie
so that was yet another exhausting day I
think we can all relate to this one in
one way or another especially down to
the worm slug-like method of
transportation so thank you again let me
know if you've got any other weird games
that you want me to play down the
comments below and if you want to help
me make cool stuff click that big join
button see all the perks you get for
supporting the channel thank you
everybody so much and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
you